my question was only what do I do if I'm
incredibly talented guitarist who wants
to start a business where I've been
teaching people music and I've been
trying for two years and it's just not
working I think you'd probably be
smarter for that person to go find
someone who loves that game and then the
only skill you'd have to have is how do
I have the perspective in which to make
a judgment that this person actually is
good and then do I have enough skill in
negotiation so I can make a favorable
deal for myself and so if you can do
those two things you can be Justin
Bieber who's not a business guy but it's
still extraordinarily wealthy Eminem is
not a business guy he's still
extraordinary wealthy there's still ways
to play it without necessarily having
business be the game which I find kind
of interesting too because I'm not Kylie
Jenner Kylie's younger than me and
Wealthy than me when I found out she was
a billionaire and she was younger than
me I literally like had a day where I
was like I felt horrible though I saw